[Music]
last night's America's Got Talent it had
its fair share of technical difficulties
but that's the beauty of life right
after the challenge though well they
have the judges and stitches it was one
of the nuttiest crazy shows I have ever
done in my life was so surreal that's
why I was laughing in the middle I
thought this is cons are so crazy when I
we've got these dolphins I couldn't stop
laughing
adding to the insanity at several
glitches with the equipment we had these
really cool doors but they're not
working right now that we're broken at
the director couple minutes before the
show said you know attire is unison in
the middle and we're just gonna show it
and you can see the crew hustling behind
her and another mishap the audience
couldn't miss was when the monitors went
haywire there's something going behind
you which is f4 comedian is incredibly
distracting still the live show ranked
number one last night pulling in 11
million viewers and executive producer
Simon who just signed a multi-year deal
with the show as another reason to
celebrate today he got a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame it is so surreal
I cannot tell you supporting Simon along
the agc judges were some of the singers
whose careers he has kick-started like
Idol alums Kelly Clarkson at a Lambert
and katharine McPhee also their former
Idol judge Randy Jackson and Simon's
girlfriend Lauren and son Eric he's the
apple of my eye
and just seeing him here today I'm
afraid one day he'll be standing up
there doesn't realize what a big deal
this is done I don't think so because
when he was asked whether I deserve it
apparently the answer was no
[Music]